Japanese scientists have recently successfully
turned mice translucent.
Hi there viewers, Julian here for DNews.
Translucent animals are more common than you
probably think, in that they actually already
exist.
Most of the naturally occurring ones are found
in the deep ocean.
There’s so little light that reflecting
any that does reach that far down can make
them a tasty piece of deep sea horror sushi.
So a lot of deep sea critters are see-through
to avoid that.
You might notice a lot of them are red or
a transparent pink too, because red light’s
long wavelength means it has low energy and
doesn’t penetrate water well.
Thus animals that only reflect red light are
essentially invisible down there.
Isn’t science neat?
Up here there’s not much point in having
transparent skin.
There’s so much light that being a gooey
see-through blob of floating bones and organs
is going to be a bit more noticeable than
being the same color as your surrounds, so
it doesn’t really make sense.
Of course scientists aren’t hampered by
your precious “logic” and have bred a
few frogs and goldfish to have see through
skin.
Researchers in Japan took the most pale ones
they could find and kept breeding them together.
The goal is to be able to observe the internal
organs while the animal is alive, making it
easier to keep track of tumor growth and how
they react to chemicals.
This for me raises an important philosophical
question.
No it’s not, “should scientists play god?”
I want to know what you call a see through
goldfish.
But now there’s a way to turn the skin,
brain, lungs, the whole shebang except the
bones clear.
A team at the RIKEN quantitative biology center
in Osaka pulled off the trick on mice by flushing
out their circulatory systems with saline
and then pumping a chemical through them for
2 weeks.
The chemical removes heme from the mice.
Heme is found in most tissue and is the “heme”
part of hemoglobin, it’s the compound in
blood that binds to oxygen and also gives
it its red tint.
Fun fact: your blood is always red, regardless
of whether or not it has oxygen.
Remember what I said about red light not being
able to penetrate well because of it’s low
energy?
That’s why your veins look blue under your
skin.
Totally transparent mice make it possible
to see the cellular networks inside tissue.
Hiroki Ueda, who led the team, hopes it can
be used to gain a better understanding of
cancer or autoimmune diseases by being able
to observe how they develop without having
to dissect the mice.
As it so often goes though, the mice don’t
get off easy.
Being stripped of blood and then heme entirely
is pretty much game over.
But I for one am resting easier knowing that
there’s no nightmare fuel jell-o mice running
around with the chance to escape and breed
and form an invisible army of horror and cheese
theft.
If you want to learn another way to turn yourself
invisible while keeping all your blood in
you, Amy’s got a video on that over here.
If you’ve got a story of a time science
did something awesome for lab mice, I want
to hear about it in the comments.
I’m not a vegetarian or anything, but I
can only read so many stories about lab mice
before I need a pick me up.
Until then, I’ll see you next time on DNews.